[Music]
afghanistan's hospitals are filled with
the wall wounded
many of them children
the latest here is a 13 year old girl
she's never known peace the doctors will
patch her up and remove the shrapnel in
her
but she'll emerge back into a country
where survival is getting harder and
harder
there's been a spike in fatalities and
casualties
as allied troops begin to pull out after
nearly 20 years
and the afghans fear it'll only get
worse
no one's safe not even medics saving
lives
he's a doctor shot after refusing an
x-ray on a patient he suspected had
coronavirus
there are multiple dangers facing
everyone in this country
and he signals his appreciation to his
fellow medics
but despite his bravery he's vulnerable
because he also works with the americans
many who worked alongside the u.s troops
are fleeing for their lives
fatima that's not her real name and her
children
have gone into hiding after death
threats from the taliban for her work
and empowering other women
she thought she was building a new and
better afghanistan
but now she's viewed as a spy and enemy
collaborator by the taliban
and her former u.s partners are leaving
her to face the fighters
alone
i feel extremely abandoned uh i am i'm
in danger it's not only that i am in
danger now my kids are in danger also
because now you know they came behind my
door they sent me
you know the messages through the phone
they got in touch with me
in many different ways so so it's the
lives of my children and myself
both of us especially my kids at this
point
they want they won't leave us they won't
leave me alive
i'm worried about about about my people
what's going to be happening with them
female activists like mabuha
told us of the fear of the advancing
taliban
unfortunately okay she and her staff are
trying to arrange
emergency flights for fellow human
rights defenders in cities now
surrounded by taliban fighters
i was given rare access and allowed to
film inside a secret refuge she runs for
dozens of women
no men are permitted to cross the
threshold
every woman and child in here has run
away or been rescued from abuse and
violence
and they're terrified of the return of
the taliban
their worst fear is that they will
disrespect them
they will use them abuse them or molest
them or whatever
and also they will kill them and then
there's one of them that is afraid or
that her
her two children will be taken by their
father because their father is
here they don't believe the taliban
reassurances that they've changed
they tell me of shocking lives of forced
marriages of beatings of rapes
where they have no say and no rights and
that is what they believe the taliban
envisage for women
this 21 year old told how she was being
forced to marry a 13 year old boy
i felt like my life was falling apart
she says until i got here
their fear of the taliban is real and
growing
as the group gets stronger and snatches
more territory
another says she too was forced to marry
a young boy and repeatedly beaten by her
in-laws with the taliban empowered
will this just get worse
i think it's definitely going to get
worse she says
the young women of today's afghanistan
have had a glimpse of
free thinking and independence
although those in this taekwondo club
have all battled family disapproval to
be here
and their martial arts training combine
the skills
necessary in this country how to survive
bomb blasts and bullets all but one has
been caught up in terror incidents
many near their schools the taliban
insists they're more relaxed about girls
schooling but their learning centers are
still
frequently attacked weeks before the
pull-out of international troops
a car bomb detonated outside a girl's
high school in the capital
killed at least 90 people every girl
here knows
they're risking death every time they
set off to learn
how scared are you about going to school
i'm scared a lot whenever i leave my
house i'm scared
because we don't know if we'll come back
alive she says
18 year old katera gets emotional
telling us she won't give up trying to
be a lawyer
the explosions are normal to us now she
says
she's not afraid for herself but she's
terrified her family will be killed
have you lost anyone
my cousin and uncle died in an explosion
she says
almost everyone here has experienced
death
parts of afghanistan are unrecognizable
to taliban times
women owning and running their own
businesses like this cafe
but they fear they'll be amongst the
first to be banned by a taliban regime
there's a new generation who've grown up
with these small freedoms
and they want more not less i'm not
feeling good because if they come back
to afghanistan so we
will have lost all of these rights to go
out or even go out of home i don't like
a scarf
but i i can like she has to
wear her scarf if taliban come i have to
wear a scarf
and it's awful for me
next door to the cafe there's a beauty
salon again
owned and run by a woman all this was
taboo under the taliban regime
and many fear it won't be long before
the strict rules about what women can
and can't do are enforced again
on top of the hills surrounding the
capital there are monuments to
the school children killed in terror
explosions
and these graves are still increasing
with few optimistic about afghanistan's
immediate future
alex crawford sky news kabul